Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen. Wie geht's?
Guten Morgen Tim. Wie geht's? Ganz ganz gut. Bin müde. Bin bisschen müde, ja.
Bisschen müde. Ja. Ist auch nicht schlecht. Hast du deine Schlafzimmerstimme sozusagen wieder am.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich habe ja hier auch schon wieder ordentlich club Mate äh rein äh Mess.
Fehlt mir noch.
Holst du dir Club Mathe, wir können ja mal hier äh holen. Ja. Ja, wenn wir eine mitbringst.
Ja, darf ich? Du hast doch noch eine.
Ja, warte mal, lange Sendung hier vor uns. Ja.
Okay, dann bereite ich mich mal äh drauf vor. Du kannst ja schon mal äh das erste äh Thema einleiten.
Ja äh Thema, auf also ganz alleine, ja okay, ich versuche mal, also,
Nee, ich kann das nicht alleine. Wir müssen jetzt, äh, ich erzähle was anderes. Und zwar, ähm, hat der Tim mir grade erzählt, ähm, von seinem neuen iPhonekabel,
Das ist ein ganz tolles Kabel. Das ist ähm das hat einen neuen Stecker und äh kostet zwanzig Euro und das ist äh einfach ein Bombenpreis für so ein tolles Kabel.
Ja, ist einfach eine super Strafgebühr. Ich finde, man muss auch, man muss auch leiden für seinen Luxus.
So Thema Nummer eins.
Die Tagesschau-App. Tagesschau-App hier für dein iPhone, insofern habe ich jetzt erst, ne, von dem Kabel äh zum iPhone,
Die Tagesschau-App herausgegeben von der ARD und
eine App für das für das iPhone, äh wurde vom Landgericht Köln ähm für äh Verboten erklärt.
Und zwar in in einer Version vom fünfzehnten Juni äh zweitausendelf. Der Hintergrund ist, dass die Zeitungsverlage,
gegen die ARD geklagt haben.
Sind denn die Zeitungsverlage eigentlich in dem Zusammenhang?
Ähm oh, das sind siebenundzwanzig Stück.
So einzeln zusammengetan haben oder hat da einen Verband geklagt, also.
Ich ähm ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es der BDZ V war.
Mhm.
Aber wir schauen jetzt nochmal ganz schnell.
Genau.
Äh Tagesschau.
Die hier jetzt schon wieder mit dem mit der Nachfrage, ne?
Ja, du.
Zeitungsverlagen, ja, da also ich weiß, dass da unter anderem der süddeutsche,
zugehört hat und viele, viele andere, die dann auch entsprechend gejubelt haben. Ja genau, der BDZV, der Bundesverband Deutscher Zeitungsverlage,
ähm zu den Klägern gehörte Axel Springer Süddeutsche FAZ und die WAZ-Mediengruppe,
Äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob's jetzt genau siebenundzwanzig waren, das war jetzt so meine Grob, gefühlt siebenundzwanzig Verlage, haben sich da zusammengetagt und fanden die war die Tagesschau-App nicht in Ordnung. Ja, Tagesschau-App kennt man, ist eine eine schöne App,
Sie äh läuft auf dem auf dem iPhone und ähm ab und zu macht das iPhone dann den Tagesschau Gong,
Per Push-Mitteilung und dann steht da, weiß ich nicht. Ähm jetzt zum Beispiel letzten Stand Türkei ähm greift Ziele in Syrien an oder so.
Tagesschau Gong macht es. Dong. Ah, ist das nicht ganz schön teuer? Da muss man doch auch wieder Unmengen an.
Ich weiß nicht, wer den Gong, ich weiß nicht, wie die GEMA, wie die rechtliche Situation um den Gong ist.
Immerhin eine ganze Note, ja, also.
Ja, also ist auf jeden Fall Schöpfungs. Auf jeden Fall ähm,
Und da was es dort gibt sind natürlich sehr viele textbasierte Artikel,
und ähm da beschwert sich dann der Bundesverband Deutscher Zeitungsverleger oder diese die klagenden Verlage und sagt,
unter den Bestimmungen des Rundfunkstaatsvertrag ist das,
unzulässig, was der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk dort mit dieser Tagesschau-App betreibt. Und ähm zwar ist es deshalb uns unzulässig, weil es einen Wettbewerbsverstoß darstellt ähm,
da der öffentlich rechtliche Rundfunk ja öffentlich-rechtlich finanziert ist. Und was sie dort machen, ist quasi ein sie bauen etwas, was als Ersatz für die Lektüre von Zeitungen und Zeitschriften.
Dienen kann,
Etwas, das eine Informationsdichte hat, die an herkömmliche Presse äh Erzeugnisse heranreicht und nicht mehr als äh quasi Begleit-App zum Fernsehen zu werten ist.
Die Tagesschau-App hat, weiß, dass sie auch sehr gut funktioniert, ohne dass man die ARD eingeschaltet hat, äh nämlich sogar besser, wenn man nicht nebenbei fernsieht. Ähm und weiß dann, womit gemeint ist. Äh was was damit gemeint ist. Ähm,
Was das die App sich im großen Rahmen bemüht, die Artikel immer mit Hörfunk und Fernsehbeiträgen zu verbinden, zu verknüpfen,
ähm ändert eigentlich daran nichts, dass hier hauptsächlich Text äh und Bilder darstellt,
Laut Argumentation des Gerichtes und das wäre außerdem sowieso nicht in ausreichenden Maße der Fall. Also es ist nicht wirklich immer sendungsbezogen, was in dieser Tagesschau-App,
zu lesen ist. Es stimmt auch, ich sehe die äh App äh ungefähr auf einem äh Niveau mit Spiegel Online, wobei Spiegel Online noch ein bisschen weniger äh Videos hat,
ja? Ähm.
Na ja, also ich meine, im Wesentlichen ist es eigentlich derselbe Inhalt wie die Webseite und ich sehe da gar keinen großen nennenswerten, inhaltlichen Unterschied. Es ist für ein funktionaler Unterschied, aber es ist kein inhaltlicher.
Ist richtig, ich glaube der Grund, warum sie sich über die, warum sich mit der App anlegen wollten, war das ähm dass man natürlich mit den Apps irgendwie anscheinend äh wirklich einen Markt hat, wo etwas vertrieben wird, während diese Webseiten irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen unter einen anderen Rahmen fallen oder so. Ne, also die.
Weil sie die eh nicht äh vermarktet bekommen oder was, aber ich meine, da haben sie ja auch ihre Werbung, das ist doch alles total absurd.
Also genau, ich ich find's auch wirklich, ich find's wirklich äh äh sehr bedauerlich, dass es den Zeitungsverlagen möglich ist, sich ähm,
sich zu so einem Urteil zu verhelfen, ja? Also dass du ein öffentlich-rechtlich, finanziertes,
System dort mit dieser App, dass es dass es überhaupt irgendein Verlag gibt, der irgendeine irgendeine Handhabe hat
sich dagegen sich dagegen zu wehren. Aber sie feiern das natürlich alles als Sternstunde der Demokratie, weil durch die Monopolstellung der ARD, die dürfe sich jetzt nicht auch noch,
auf den, auf die Freie Presse.
Monopolstellung.
Ausweiten, ja so ungefähr oder so irisch ihre, ja doch, also ihre starke staatlich finanzierte
wettbewerbsverzerrende Stellung ja? Dadurch dass sie durch diese Gebühren unabhängig sind und ja also das dürfte sonst hätten wir nämlich so 'ne also die die
Pressverlage schreiben in ihren Artikeln dann so etwas herbei, wie so die die Einheits ähm,
Es droht quasi die das sozialistische Einheitsmedium in Form dieser Tagesschau-App,
und äh die äh äh Speerspitzen der demokratischen äh freien Presse haben, die sie jetzt in ihre Schranken gewiesen,
So, das ist also die offizielle Geschichteschreibung, zumindest in den äh Publikationen jener Verlagshäuser, die äh sich an dieser Klage beteiligt haben.
Bildzeichen wird sozusagen in ihrer basisdemokratischen Grund.
Genau, ja, ja. Ähm,
Also um nochmal ganz kurz äh die Argumentation des Gerichtes äh schließt also damit, dass diese diese App in der Form verboten ist. Äh.
Aber das bezieht sich nur auf die Version vom.
Ja Moment, Moment, ich will, komme ich ja gleich, komme ich ja gleich zum.
Okay.
Weil die Presse ähnlichen
und nicht Sendungsbezogenen Beiträge einen breiten Raum einnehmen. Das Angebot optisch dominieren und den Gesamteindruck wesentlich mitbestimmen. Das heißt also
die ARD darf keine Presseerzeugnisse machen und diese App geht dem zu nahe dran. Er kommt dem zu nah?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen vermutlich weil es irgendwie nur ein kleines Landgericht ist, bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf die Tagesschau vom fünfzehnten Juni zweitausendelf, die da geprüft wurde, diese Version,
Ähm.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar wieso, wahrscheinlich gab's einfach eine Prüfung an dem Tag von dieser App-Version und fertig war die Laube so.
Na, das war dann sozusagen die App, die in den äh in den Akten abgeheftet wurde und äh spätere Updates haben's da halt nicht mehr reingeschafft. Das war dann sozusagen nach Redaktionsschluss.
Ungefähr so war das, ja. Ähm.
Allgemeine allgemeine allgemeine Einschätzung der der der Juristen ist, dass dieses Urteil im Zweifelsfall kein,
Bestand haben wird und ähm die ARD prüft natürlich auch irgendwie eine Berufung äh dagegen,
Aber es ist erstmal für die Verleger ein Etappensieg, die es ernsthaft, also die die Verleger, die uns jetzt ernsthaft die Tagesschau-App vom vom iPhone klagen wollen. Aber, wie gesagt, ähm,
ARD prüft äh Berufung dagegen. Aber wir haben echt auch wirklich Leute, die ähm die dieses Urteil ähm,
begrüßen. Ja, sagen sie die die öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkanstalten sollen sich auf ihre Kernaufgaben konzentrieren, sagt zum Beispiel der äh Medienbeauftragte der Bundesregierung, Bernd Neumann,
ähm Jan Eumann Medienstaatssekretär der Nordrhein-Westfalen,
sieht das anders, es gibt weder Gewinner noch Verlierer und es muss jetzt irgendwie ein Dialog her, aber man fragt sich natürlich ohnehin,
warum? Also mir ist nicht ganz klar, was das soll, ne. Also warum warum beschränkt man die warum beschränkt man die ARD.
Und.
Für ein kostenloses Angebot. Also es ist ja, ist mir auch vollkommen.
Mir sind mehrere Sachen vollkommen unklar. Also erstmal, wie ein Gericht überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, dass jetzt äh dieselbe Information, wie sie auf der Webseite ist, verpackt in eine Software irgendwas anderes ist in der Informationsdarreichung als diese Webseite, weil nach der Logik müsste man ja auch die Webseite äh vom Stand fünfzehnter Juni zwanzig elf äh
schließen, ja? Das könnt ihr sie auch gleich noch mit anweisen. Was auch irgendwie keinen Sinn macht und ich meine, das,
Macht die Tagesschau jetzt solche Beiträge, seit wie viel Jahren gibt's Tagesschau DE lange? Oder.
Relativ lange, ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, seit wann.
Und ich meine, das will doch wohl keiner ernsthaft behaupten, dass die Tagesschau äh nicht mit einem vergleichbaren Angebot äh im Internet sein sollte, wie zum Beispiel die BBC.
Ja, äh das also das Problem ist, es gibt natürlich eine rechtliche Grundlage dafür für diese für dieses Urteil. Ja, das haben die äh haben ja nicht nicht einfach so gemacht. Und zwar, das wollte ich eigentlich auch im nächsten,
äh beim nächsten Thema dann ansprechen, ist Rundfunk ein linearer Informations und Kommunikationsdienst,
Er ist für die Allgemeinheit und zum Zeitgleichen,
Er ist die für die Allgemeinheit und zum zeitgleichen Empfang bestimmte Veranstaltungen und Verbreitung von Angeboten in Bewegtbild oder Ton entlang eines Sendeplans unter Benutzung elektromagnetischer Schwingungen.
Das Wichtige ist hier, dass es linear ist, ähm zeitgleich und dass es Bewegtbild oder Ton ist.
Linear im Vergleich zu also was ist es, wenn es nicht linear ist? Nicht linear.
Dann ist es das zumindest schon mal nicht mehr. Da kommen wir beim nächsten Thema zu. Es ist schon mal kein Rundfunk mehr. Ähm.
Nicht lineare Informationsausstrahlung. Ah.
Podcasts sind kein Rundfunk nach der Definition, weil die kann sich jeder herunterladen, wann er möchte. Und im äh Rundfunk äh Staatsvertrag.
Ähm ist das eben als Rundfunk definiert. Und der ARD wird gesagt, ihr macht Rundfunk.
Ja, das heißt, wir müssten eigentlich auch konsequenterweise den Tagesschau-Podcast äh verbieten.
Tim, du nimmst das nächste Thema vorweg. Insofern springen wir jetzt einfach mal äh zum nächsten Thema. Und zwar ähm.
Also komplett zu einem neuen Thema, meinst du jetzt? Oder zu einem neuen.
Naja, du du nimmst grade so ein bisschen die die die Reihenfolge, wie ich die Geschichte erzählen will, machst du gerade.
Entschuldigung, ich halt's Maul jetzt. Ich bin ruhig, aber ich versuche ja nur mitzudenken.
Nee, ist, also es, ist, ist, ist, äh, du springst so ein bisschen zu schnell. Deswegen, wir wir machen mal noch mal einen Schritt zurück. Also, fest, fest steht, es gibt eine Definition von Rundfunk
nach dieser hat die ARD und die ZDF äh ZDF und so zu arbeiten und wenn sie diese Definition,
wenn sie sich dieser äh von dieser Definition entfernen, dann haben sie keinen rechtlichen Rahmen dafür und dann.
Ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Zu solchen Urteilen.
Ja, man will ja auch nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie Dating-Hotlines starten und so weiter.
Seit wann heißt der äh heißt der, genau, du willst zum Beispiel nicht, dass sie eine Dating-Hotline oder eine Online-Community oder irgendwie sowas betreiben. Warum gibt es das? Ja, das geht zurück auf ähm.
Online-Community hätte ich nichts.
Dürfen sie aber auch nicht,
So und zwar geht das zurück auf zweitausenddrei. Wir werfen jetzt die ganzen Themen zusammen. Zweitausenddrei ähm ging es los mit einer Beschwerde des Verbandes privater Rundfunk und Telemedien. Das sind dann so die Privatfernsehenanbieter,
Ähm und die beschweren sich bei der EU Kommission und sagen ähm,
die deutsche Rundfunkgebühr GEZ ist eine unzulässige staatliche Beihilfe,
ähm und verstößt damit gegen irgendwie Artikel siebenundachtzig äh des Vertrags zur Gründung der europäischen Gemeinschaft,
weil es eine wettbewerbszerrende Finanzierung ist und Privatunternehmen benachteiligt. Ähm.
Und haben sich hauptsächlich darüber beklagt, dass die Rundfunkanstalten keinen engen begrenzten Funktionsauftrag hatten. Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt haben die Zeitungsverlegerargument äh die die
äh Privat-TV-Anbieter argumentiert. Die ARD kann mit dem Geld, was Sie über die GEZ einzieht, im Prinzip alles machen.
Und ähm da muss was muss was gegen getan werden. Dann hat die ARD zweitausendsieben,
ihre neue Onlinestrategie vorgestellt und gesagt, guck mal hier, wir machen jetzt äh noch sehr viel, sehr viel spannender mit Internet und äh wir schreiben noch einen schönen Artikel und wir stellen uns ein paar Journalisten ein,
Das war also zweitausendsieben und dann war auch der Bundesverband der deutschen Zeitungsverlage äh am Nörgeln. Das heißt, dann hatten sie sich nicht nur mit dem Privatfernsehen angelegt, sondern auch mit dem äh mit den Zeitungsverlagen.
Und dann wurde zweitausendsieben ein Urteil gesprochen des Bundesverfassungsgericht, ähm dass der dass der ARD zugesprochen hat, dass sie überhaupt irgendwie was im Internet machen darf,
Ja, dass also es ging quasi echt so darum,
dass sie, dass sie die quasi schon die ARD eigentlich fast aus dem Internet rausklagen wollten. Da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht aber gesagt, naja die darf erstmal grundsätzlich dürfen die Rundfunk veranstalten wo sie wollen
aber es muss ein Beihilfe-Kompromiss geschlossen werden, dass nämlich bis zweitausendneun das geregelt wird im
Rundfunkänderung, Staatsvertrag, dass es eine engere Definition dessen gibt, was Rundfunk ist,
Und damit haben sie das EU-Verfahren äh,
abgewendet. So und dann kam eben im zweitausendneun im Rundfunkänderung Staatsvertrag.
Diese Definition zustande, wo man also sagt, Rundfunk ist zeitlich linear Bild und Ton. Und
Sie dürfen zum Beispiel nicht irgendwie eine Online-Community betreiben, also irgendein Facebook oder so. Sie dürfen
keinen großartigen Tralara mit äh User Generation Content machen und es muss zeitlich begrenzt werden. Und dabei kam es zu dieser völlig beknackten Regelung
Publikation. Die war eine Folge von diesem Rundfunkänderungsstaatsvertrag,
Depublikation, ein großes Ärgernis war, glaube ich, Thema so um zweitausendzehn, als es dann wirklich losging mit der Depoliziererei. Er wurde nämlich gesagt, okay, die ARD unterhält da ihre äh ihre Mediathek und so,
und da sind Beiträge drin, die sind teilweise ein Jahr alt.
Und da aber äh Rundfunk zeitlich linear begrenzt, entlang Sendeplan und so weiter sein muss, dürfen die halt gar nicht,
müssen ihre Inhalte nach einer Zeit wieder herausnehmen,
dürfen die nicht dauerhaft online stellen. Und das ist allgemein eine Dauer von sieben Tagen.
Die, die ihren Kram da online stellen dürfen. Ähm bei Fußballspielen sind es nur vierundzwanzig Stunden,
Weil da irgendwie ist halt so, keine Ahnung, weil vermutlich weil die Rechte für sieben Tage viel zu teuer wären beim Fußballspiel,
und bei bestimmten Bildungs- und Kultursendungen kann sich das mal auf ein Jahr ausweihen,
Ähm wie lange sie also diese diese Sendung dort vorhalten dürfen. Ähm.
Ja, so ist die Regelung und so leiden wir äh alle da drunter und das war sozusagen die Kröte, die sie äh geschluckt haben, um sozusagen überhaupt äh erstmal ins Internet gelassen zu werden. Kann man sich durchaus vorstellen, dass das nicht so.
Na ja, sie, dass das nicht zu, sie waren zu dem Zeitpunkt schon schön im Internet drin. Äh es ging dann äh.
Vorbehalt, dass es eben neu geregelt werden muss und dann kam diese Neuregelung und die hat dann halt gesagt, so ja okay, jetzt dürfte er auch bleiben, aber äh
hauen euch halt ein bisschen auf die Finger und dann haben sie irgendwie glaube ich nicht so richtig verstanden, dass das an sich eine Schnapsidee ist. Auch wenn ich durchaus sehe und äh,
Da kämen jetzt sicherlich auch gleich die Kommentare dazu, wenn man diesen Aspekt nicht aufgreifen würde
dass das Ganze alles an unglaublicher Rattenschwanz an an rechtlichen Konsequenzen ist mit dieser ganzen dauerhaften Publikation im Netz. Weil so
Modelle für Autoren et cetera, die natürlich auch alle gleich den Finger heben
Früher kriechtest du oder ist ja auch immer noch so, wenn du nochmal eine Neuausstrahlung hast, dann gibt's ja dann auch wieder äh entsprechende Ausschüttungen, äh was ist, wenn jetzt so ein Tatort,
Forever im äh äh Internet steht quasi zum Download äh ja, man muss dann dann auch mehr gezahlt werden, kann man sich das überhaupt leisten? Wie ist das überhaupt rechtlich, Urheberrecht et cetera, Widerspruchsrechte? Das fällt da alles mit rein.
Was ähm nicht zu Verachtnisse sind, aber die Kosten, die die ARD dadurch hat, diese Depublikation zu betreiben. Ähm wir hatten erstmal einen Riesenärger und haben Ewigkeiten gebraucht, ihr bis dahin,
Äh vorhandenes Archiv aufzuräumen. Dieses Archiv ähm,
Er musste quasi durch alle Sendungen durchgeschaut werden, musste die Sendung kategorisiert werden.
Depubliziert werden oder einige eben vielleicht was 'ne Kultursendung, die konnte dann noch hatte vielleicht noch sechs Monate Frist, die sie online bleiben könnte,
und sie haben jetzt eine ganze Menge Personen angestellt, die die sich nur darum kümmern, weil sie eben dann auch noch zu allem Überfluss diese unterschiedlichen Fristen haben für verschiedene. Ähm für verschiedene Sendungen. Es war damals so ähm dass,
auf magische Weise ein komplettes Sendungsarchiv der Tagesschau und so auf äh The Pirate Bay auftauchte. Ähm es tauchte dann die Webseite,
Punkt org glaube ich auf
äh bei der äh Terabyte Weise ARD-Material äh zu finden war, was äh so die Legende vor der Republikation von einem äh findigen Downloader alles von der ARD-Seite geholt wurde,
geholt worden war. Ähm.
Das Problem und da kommen wir ja jetzt zu, ist der der Grund, warum sie es herausnehmen müssen,
ist, weil sie öffentlich finanziert sind durch eine Zwangsabgabe, die auf Mensch, die den Menschen aufgebürdet wird, nämlich die GEZ,
GEZ-Gebühr die Gebühren, Einzugszentrale Gebühr, die äh wir alle entrichten müssen. Ähm da gab's quasi der Grund, dass sie zwangsfinanziert sind,
ist oder äh dass sie depublizieren müssen. Der Grund dafür ist, dass sie zwangsfinanziert sind.
Und gleichzeitig würde man ja sagen, wenn sie schon öffentlich zwangsfinanziert sind, dann soll doch wenigstens auch der Kram da bleiben. Er wurde ja schließlich bezahlt. Er ist ja vergold,
Ja, das also, das ist eigentlich das das Dramatische an dieser Geschichte, ja, dass du dass dass uns quasi Geld abgenommen wird als Bürger, um uns einen einen öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk zu gönnen. Das ist eine ganz tolle Sache. Ich meine, man kann auch, ich verstehe auch nicht
wie privat, Fernsehen ernsthaft behaupten kann, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk für sie eine Konkurrenz darstellt. Die beackern doch ein komplett anderes Feld
einzige, der einzige Punkt, wo ich sehe, dass die konkurrieren, ist, wenn's um Fußball geht. Das wollen die die Rechte wollen die immer beide haben,
und ärgern sich, wenn der, wenn wenn der andere sie hat, ja? Aber ähm.
Es geht auch um Einnahmen, ja, weil äh letztlich äh sind die Öffentlichen halt auch in im Werbung und Sponsorengeschäft unterwegs, was ich auch äh.
Na ja, zumindest für fragwürdig äh halte. Kann man auch so oder so sehen.
Genau, der deswegen gibt's ja auch, also da gibt's ja sicherlich auch alle möglichen Klange, beziehungsweise die habe ich den Eindruck, sind schon gefühlte Jahrzehnte her. Das zum Beispiel im öffentlich-rechtlichen nach äh zwanzig Uhr, glaube ich, keine Währung mehr laufen darf oder läuft.
Nee, das regelt ein Bundesgesetz, also ich meine bei Fußballweltmeisterschaft et cetera, da hast du dann auch immer gleich dein Bierchen direkt äh in der Halbzeitspause noch aufm Schirm.
Ach stimmt ja, da haben sie auch nach dem Tatort kommt auch nochmal kurz Krombacher oder sowas, ne? Ja.
Das weiß ich nicht, aber das ist äh mindestens aufgeweicht, aber ist natürlich eine grundsätzliche Frage. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen einen unabhängigen Journalismus haben, dann möchte man natürlich eigentlich auch äh diesen Journalismus von solchen Werbezwängen,
so ein Drittmittel generierendes Element, würde man ja eigentlich gerne rausnehmen. Das würde dann beim Fußball zwangsläufig dazu führen, dass die äh Lizenzkosten,
um sowas nur noch von privaten getragen werden könnte. So, wo ich auch sagen muss.
Ja, okay, ja. Andererseits müsste die Rechtslage auch sagen,
Dinge, die eben von einem großen öffentlichen Interesse sind,
Da muss auch drüber berichtet werden können, ja. Gut, dann ist es halt so mit den Recht auf Bild und wer dacht, da filmen und so weiter, das ist halt einfach auch generell ein ein Minenfeld,
Und von daher ist die ganze Diskussion äh nicht einfach, aber es würde langfristig schon dazu führen, dass äh das öffentlich-rechtliche Programm,
bestimmten Bereichen eben so nicht mithalten könnte mit den privaten Angeboten. Aber man muss auch die Frage stellen,
Müssen sie das unbedingt, ja? Ist es wirklich erforderlich.
Im Moment ist, also ich weiß, was du was du gerade sagst, aber im Moment sieht die Lage echt anders aus, also was was vor Gericht argumentiert wird, sagen die Privaten, sie könnten nicht mit den, mit dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen mithalten.
Ja, in welchem Bereich.
Na ja, in in in dem Bereich, wo sie überall gegen die klagen, ja, also wo sie, wo sie dann sagen, macht, macht eure Apps aus, äh.
Ja, ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie von den Privaten besonders viel Artikel im äh äh Netz erscheinen würden, so. Also genau das, was.
Da war's ja, da waren's ja die Zeitungsverlage. Also es gibt Zeitungsverlage und privat.
Das habe ich jetzt durcheinander gebracht. Da hast du natürlich recht. Ja gut.
Aber vielleicht nochmal nochmal zurück zur oder nochmal jetzt zur GEZ-Gebühr, ja? Also es wird also
zwangserhoben die GEZ-Gebühren. Da gab's auch jetzt ein sehr schönes, sehr schönes Urteil in der letzten Woche. Und zwar ist ja seit einiger Zeit so, dass die GEZ-Gebühr auf
Computer ausgeweitet wurde.
Und man momentan äh meine ich, äh fünf Euro noch was, GEZ-Gebühr für einen Computer zahlt im Monat. Ähm sofern er internetfähig ist,
ähm muss man muss man diese diese Gebühr entrichten. Ich kenne mich da zugegebenermaßen im Detail nicht so genau aus. Auf jeden Fall,
hat jemand dagegen geklagt?
Und vor allem hat er klagt er deswegen, weil auch in Büros, wenn du dort Rechner stehen hast, äh fällt dafür eine GEZ-Gebühr an. Und dagegen hat sich ein Rechtsanwalt zur Wehr gesetzt, der sagte, ich habe hier Internet,
Ich habe hier Computer, sind multifunktionale Geräte, die hier in einem Büroalltag zum Einsatz kommen und die dienen nicht vordergründig dem Rundfunkempfang,
sondern werden beruflich äh überhaupt nicht genutzt zum Rundfunk Sendung Empfang, sondern um damit zu arbeiten.
Und ähm da hatte diese Klage hat er bis zum Bundesverfassungsgericht hochgetragen und das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagte, naja,
so kannst du leider nicht argumentieren, weil wenn wir dir diese Argumentation zulassen, dann schaffen wir ein äh Schlupfloch,
zum Entkommen aus der äh Rundfunkgebühr,
Und äh deswegen darfst du so nicht argumentieren und deswegen ist es völlig ist es eine funktionsadäquate Finanzierung des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks. Wenn wir für jeden internetfähigen Computer diese Gebühr erheben.
Und interessant ab zweitausenddreizehn,
ändert sich die Gebühr ohnehin in einer Haushaltsabgabe. Im Moment ist die Gebühr ja noch daran gebunden, dass sich im Besitz eines Empfangsgerätes bin, also es gibt ähm
Radio oder neuartige Empfangsgeräte? Neuartiges Empfangsgerät ist ein Computer mit Internetanschluss. Äh es gibt TV,
Dann gibt's noch irgendwie Autoradio und so weiter und je nachdem, was du hast, musst du dann unterschiedliche Gebühren zahlen. Vollgebühr ist irgendwas siebzehn Euro, noch was für diejenigen, die noch irgendwie einen Fernseher in der Wohnung stehen haben.
Und jetzt gibt's ja diesen schönen, gibt's ja diese diese ähm,
Diese Jungs von der GEZ, die irgendwie dann anklingeln und irgendwie so äh Leute irgendwie verdonnern und Nachzahlung, die schwarz sehen, die die nicht die GEZ-Gebühr zahlen, ja, ist ja lange
Jahren gibt's ja diese Kampagnen dann schon GEZ gezahlt und und pipapo und immer mal wieder äh hörst du einen, der erwischt wird äh von der GEZ und dann ein paar hundert Euro nachzahlen muss, weil er irgendwie zehn Jahre alten Fernseher hat und,
sagen dann, okay, jetzt musst du für die ganze Zeit nachzahlen. So und ab zweitausenddreizehn soll das alles ein Ende haben,
So die positive äh äh Geschichteschreibung von Seiten der GEZ, denn dann gibt's eine Haushaltsabgabe und zwar pro Wohnstätte, egal was drin ist.
Also egal, ob da ein Computer drin steht oder nicht, jeder Haushalt zahlt eine Zwangsabgabe für äh den öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk,
Gleichzeitig sehen wir uns einer äh Situation gegenüber, wo dieser Zwangsfinanzierte notwendige öffentliche Rundfunk, der das einzige ist, was noch irgendwie ein halbwegs,
annehmbares äh Rundfunkprogramm äh in diesem Lande produziert. Gezwungen ist,
Ähm Inhalte herauszunehmen, seine Apps zu beschneiden, ähm und das aus dem Grunde, weil er öffentlich finanziert ist, ne, ist schon relativ paradoxe Situation, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ja. Äh so oder so, es ändert sich halt jetzt zwanzig, dreizehn dann doch äh grundsätzlich, ich muss sagen, dass ich den,
generell, also viele weinen natürlich jetzt, weil sie keinen Fernseher haben und irgendwie an diesem ganzen Spaß
Spaß nicht äh äh teilhaben, ohnehin schon nicht, ne? Ich weiß nicht, es gibt da noch keinen Unterschied mehr zwischen Radio und Fernsehempfang et cetera, ne, sozusagen so jeder hat seinen Beitrag zu entrichten
womit das Ganze ja eben so ein bisschen mehr wie so eine Steuer ist, wenn eben auch auf Haushaltsebene und nicht auf Personenebene.
Ja, es ist, es ist wie eine Steuer, aber es äh rechtlich gesehen ist es äh etwas ganz anderes. Das wird irgendwie immer betont. Ich habe.
Na klar, weil es halt keine Steuer ist,
so, das ist halt, das heißt halt anders. Das ist halt ein Rundfunkbeitrag und ähm ich muss sagen, persönlich finde ich das ja an sich gut, ja. Ich finde bloß eben, wie du auch,
Die Rahmendaten und die Rahmenbedingungen, unter denen eben die öffentlichen dann mit ihren Inhalten umgehen, unangemessen und ich denke, diese Diskussion wird auch noch weitergehen.
Ja, also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die ARD sich zumindest gegen dieses App-Urteil da jetzt äh zur Wehr setzen wird. Ähm aber äh wenn wir uns den den Text des äh Rundfunkänderungsstaatsvertrages, was die Definition,
von Rundfunk angeht, ähm durchlesen,
dann sieht es erstmal so aus, als wäre die aktuelle Gesetzeslage da, tatsächlich zum Nachteil des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks.
Ja, da muss halt dieser äh Rest, wie heißt der? Rest Rundfunkänderung, Staatsvertrag, dann muss.
Geändert werden, brauchen wir einen neuen, ja?
Genau, muss das ein äh Rundfunkänderung, Staatsvertragsänderungsgesetz geben. Mhm. Was das halt äh Realitätsanpassungsgesetz.
Ist ein riesen ist ein riesen äh riesen Act, ne, weil den der muss auf das ist ein, also Staatsvertrag, weil es ein Vertrag der Bundesländer ist,
ist genau wie der Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag, der dann von jedem einzelnen Bundesland ratifiziert werden muss. Das heißt, da kann nicht irgendwie mal einer hingehen, der äh eine Minute nachgedacht hat und sagen, so, jetzt machen wir mal ordentlich hier
sondern die müssen die Länder dann da untereinander aushandeln, ne? Wir haben Ewigkeiten dauern.
Ciao. Dann warten wir mal, bis das Realitätsanpassungsgesetz äh durch ist,
Bundestag. Bis dahin können wir uns ja noch mit weiteren äh Themen beschäftigen. Unser Gast von vor zwei äh Sendungen, dem Michael Krey.
Hat Post bekommen.
Post bekommen. Sie haben Post.
Wir haben, wir haben einen offenen Brief.
Sie haben einen offenen Brief bekommen. Genau.
Schöner, offener Brief kann ich jedem nur zu zu lesen nahelegen ein offener Brief der deutschen Bahn an das Projekt Open Plan B,
ähm und haben sie dann.
Die Deutsche Bahn ähm schreibt also äh an an Michael Krey ähm dass sie im Wiederholungsfall ihn ähm wieder zivil und strafrechtlich zur Verantwortung ziehen wird.
Also, erstmal muss man sagen, sie wenden sich, also sie fassen erstmal zusammen, was eben passiert ist. Äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik
berichtete. Ja, also diese Veröffentlichung der Fahrplandaten aus dieser CD-Rom
Das äh finden sie alles total äh doof und prangern das an und wie denn das überhaupt äh ginge und so geht's ja nun äh äh nicht. Und überhaupt äh äh der Herr der riecht der stinkt und riecht nach Lulu und äh mit dem wollen wir jetzt auch gar nichts mehr zu tun haben, weil der ist ja böse
obwohl wir irgendwie mit ihm gesprochen haben, hat er seine Drohung wahr gemacht und das irgendwie veröffentlicht und das ginge ja nicht, weil das ja
Urheberrechtlich davon schreiben sie doch oder?
Ja, sie haben.
Von der Lizenz.
Sie machen es, sie machen's noch ein bisschen geschickter, also sie sagen natürlich, dass er das, dass er ähm und das war ja auch klar, das hat Michael ja selber gesagt, dass er diese Lizenz, die er da er kann ja nicht Daten einfach nehmen und die unter eine andere Lizenz hauen,
aber ähm.
Was sie ihm eigentlich ankreiden und das finde ich ähm sehr schön ist, da sagen sie, ihre Aktion ist geeignet, open Data Initiativen
generell in ein negatives Licht zu rücken. Denn diese fußen auf der Garantie, dass derjenige, der eine Datenbank unter eine offene Lizenz stellt, auch berechtigt ist
dies zu tun. Mit ihrer öffentlichen Aktion stellen sie eindrucksvoll das Gegenteil unter Beweis, sie leisten der Skepsis gegenüber offenen Daten, jedwede Art
Vorschub. Hinzu kommt,
Daten verändern sich spätestens mit jedem Fahrplanwechsel und deswegen äh werden sie äh die Erwartung der Menschen, die ihren Alltag
diese Fahrplandaten ausrichten müssen, früher oder später enttäuschen. Also Michael Kreil ähm hat,
nicht die Deutsche Bahn, nein, Michael Kreil hat
einer der größten oder aktivsten deutschen Open Detaktivisten jetzt quasi Open Data den Dolchstoß gegeben, in dem er rechtsunsicherheit und,
fehlerhafte Daten in ähm unsere Welt äh geschoben hat und äh dafür rückt ihn die Deutsche Bahn.
Na sie sagen nicht, dass es fehlerhafte Daten sind.
Sie werden früher oder später fehlerhaft sein, ja? Sie sagen Daten verändern sich spätestens mit jedem Fahrplanwechsel, dritte Applikationen, die mit Hilfe der von Ihnen rechtswidrig verbreiteten Daten entwickelt werden, veralten schnell und werden daher auch zum Ärger der Entwicklung, jede Erwartung der Menschen, die Ihren Alltag ans Fahrplandaten ausrichten müssen.
Früher oder später enttäuschen. Ja.
Ja natürlich, deswegen aktualisiert man sie ja dann auch.
Sieht man sie, ja.
Also es ist.
Und als als letzter Satz äh sie werden sicherlich Verständnis dafür haben, dass die Deutsche Bahn nach ihrer illegalen Aktion
im Rahmen von möglichen Open Data Initiativen auf ihre Mitarbeit verzichten wird. Wir werden das Gespräch mit anderen Open Data Förderern suchen. Das ist der Dank
die die Deutsche Bahn hier beim ausspricht, der äh ihr den den Stoß in das kalte Wasser gibt, was äh mit dem sie sich irgendwo mal ein bisschen hätte.
Na, sie sind einfach beleidigt, weil sie jetzt irgendwie blamiert wurden in gewisser Hinsicht.
Wenn man das mal rausnimmt die Frage die ich mir jetzt natürlich gestellt habe wie immer ist sozusagen nach der rechtlichen Basi dieser Aussagen denn sie sagen ja,
Das sei illegal. Ja?
Das ist ja nun zunächst einmal eine Behauptung und ich frage mich halt gegen welches Gesetz hier eigentlich äh,
verstoßen wurde und inwiefern ein Eigentum an diesen öffentlichen, potentiell öffentlichen Informationen,
Ähm überhaupt vorliegt.
Ja, also das,
Liegt ja daran, dass die Deutsche Bahn hat auf jeden Fall erstmal diese Daten und lizensiert die und die hat die eben diesen Hafersleuten ihr Haarkonsytem lizensiert und sie hat sie an Google Maps lizensiert.
Punkt.
Ja, aber da fließt doch das Geld eher von der Bahn zur als irgendwie universelle Dienstleister et cetera. Ist ja nicht so, dass äh die Bahn jetzt äh sozusagen dieses Unternehmen für sie profizenter ist, sondern dass äh das kostet sie Geld,
Also diese Lizensierung ist ja sozusagen eher.
Kostet, kostet sie Geld und und wahrscheinlich eine Menge an Einschränkungen, äh wem sie die ganzen Daten nicht geben dürfen.
Nein, die eigentliche Frage ist ja, äh wenn diese Information als solche äh äh Vorliegen, sind sie überhaupt als solche schützbar?
Also ist, ich meine, welches welches Gesetz welches Recht ist hier gemeint?
Wir hier vom Urheberrecht ist das eine hat irgendwie ein Fahrplan, eine eine Schöpfungshöhe und gilt da irgendwie als Werk, dass er eben vom Urheberrecht gedeckt ist. Wenn nein,
was dann? Also
was ist die rechtliche Grundlage hier, mit der Sie sagen, das sei jetzt illegal gewesen? Berufen Sie sich da drauf, dass diese CD Romm irgendwie ihr Software Copyright die Daten quasi ein Teil des Software Copy Reiz sind,
Ist es das, was sie meinen? Also,
das fehlt mir so in dieser Debatte äh noch, weil man ja auch genauso argumentieren können, ja, wieso? Fahrplandaten sind irgendwie öffentlich, ihr gehört dem Staat.
Also wenn wenn ich das im im Gespräch mit Michael richtig.
Ja und ihr gibt das ja auch anderen Unternehmen.
Im Gespräch mit Michael richtig äh verstanden habe, ist äh tatsächlich nicht hundertprozentig klar, ähm,
wie man ähm,
wie das jetzt, wie die rechtliche Situation um diese Daten ist, aber es ist ja eher so, dass wenn du egal welche Daten du hast, dass die eher erstmal deinem deinem deinem Recht und deinem deiner Verfügungshoheit unterliegen als nicht,
Ja, also ich ich gehe schon einfach davon aus, dass ein irgendein Paragraphen gibt, der es der Deutschen Bahn äh erstmal nicht vorschreibt, dass diese Daten tatsächlich nicht ihr gehörten. Und deswegen macht sie natürlich irgendwie da.
Ich sage auch nicht, dass es das nicht gibt. Ich sage nur, sie benennen das nicht. Sie sprechen von Rechtsverletzungen in dem erheblichen Ausmaß, äh aber,
benennen nicht dieses Recht, was da verletzt wurde, ja? Und das das finde ich dann doch schon etwas äh skurril, dass sie sich da so weit äh aus dem Fenster lehnen mit so einem offenen Brief und der ja auch, ich meine, allein diese Form ist ja auch äh schon interessant, ne. Also was was versuchen sie damit
zu erreichen, ja? Also,
Sie jetzt hier irgendwie abschreckend wirken oder wollen sie äh da den Michael jetzt diskreditieren oder.
Sie wollen, natürlich wollen sie ihn diskreditieren. Es ist, also es ist so, scroll mal runter wert, wer hat diesen Brief da geschrieben? Ja genau, wer hat den Brief da geschrieben? Geh mal runter Birgit. Birgit, Bowle, so wird nächstes Jahr.
Na ja, sie schaffen ja zunächst einmal eine unglaubliche Öffentlichkeit dafür, ne, dass naja, das ist hier die äh Birgit Birgit Bowler, Vorsitzende der Geschäftsführung der DB Vertrieb GmbH.
Okay, wenn sie Vorsitzender Geschäftsführerin ist, wird sie vielleicht nicht nächstes Jahr Bewerbungen schreiben. Aber jemand, der ähm, also wer auch immer sie ihr zu diesem Brief geraten hat, wird nächstes Jahr Bewerbungen schreiben.
Weil ähm also wie wie die Deutsche Bahn sich irgendwie die Blöße geben kann
so einen beknackten Brief an so eine Nischengrüppchen dazu schreiben, ähm ist mir völlig, völlig zweifelhaft, ja.
Ja, mir ist auch nicht klar, was was da so die Stoßrichtung äh ist. Und das ist, ich meine, ich finde es einfach generell, äh schade. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau,
Was ihre Bedenken wirklich sind, ne? Ich meine, da sind wir auch als wir das hier besprochen haben, nicht wirklich schlau draus geworden. Aber.
Wenn die Daten richtig sind, davon ist ja davon auszugehen, dann kann man zumindest nicht damit argumentieren, dass da irgendwie ein Schaden von ausgeht. Und wenn die Daten alt sind, dann weiß man das auch.
Ich meine, das ist ja klar, dass die alt sind.
Die Deutsche Bahn hat zunächst einmal selber relativ offensichtlich überhaupt nicht die Kompetenz oder die Ressourcen mit diesen Daten vernünftig umzugehen
Das ist ihr äh das ist schon mal ihr Hauptproblem, sonst hätten sie ja nicht auf einen externen Dienstleister zugreifen
und dem irgendwie dieses ganze Geld da geben und sich noch irgendwie rechtlich von dem einzwängen lassen diese diese Fahrkartenplattform dazu unterhalten
Sie haben offensichtlich die die Ressourcen und die Kompetenzen nicht im eigenen Hause ihre Fahrplandaten vernünftig aufzubereiten.
Zu veröffentlichen. Darum geht's.
Veröffentlichen. Also intern werden sie auf.
Zu erstellen tun sie die ja nun selber. Ich meine das äh ist wirklich ihre Kernkompetenz, die möchte ich ihnen gar nicht absprechen.
Nee, sie haben die, aber sie können sie offensichtlich nicht, äh, so was wie eine Buchungsplattform oder eine äh äh Rauting-Plattform für solche Dinge selber machen. Und haben,
Mit hoher Sicherheit einfach ähm mit diesem Hafersystem oder Haarkornsystem äh bestimmte Verträge, die natürlich,
Wenn ich für die Deutsche Bahn äh den Auftrag bekomme, deren Fahrkarten-App zu machen, Web äh Applikationen, dann mache ich selbstverständlich, steht in dem Vertrag drin, dass ich da bestimmte Exklusivrechte dran habe, sonst schmeiße ich doch nicht
weiß ich nicht wie viel hunderttausend Mannstunden da drauf eine Onlinebuchungsplattform zu machen,
auf einmal die Gefahr sehen muss, dass ähm dass das jeder andere auch machen kann und die Gefahr ist, dass er es besser kann.
Also habe ich äh irgendwelche äh Exklusivrechte vertraglich ausgehandelt und diese Exklusivrechte fußen letztendlich wieder darauf, dass die Bahn erstmal die äh der Inhaber dieser Daten ist und die erstmal per se nicht offen sind.
Also.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich würde mir, ich würde mir wünschen, ähm dass da einfach,
Offener diskutiert werden würde und nicht unbedingt in Form von offenen Briefen, sondern dass wir mal äh ihre Bedenken, die sie da äh offensichtlicher Michael auch entgegengebracht haben, auch mal öffentlich diskutieren und das mal ganz ergebnisoffen auch äh in Raum stellen.
Würde ich mir wünschen.
Ja, würde ich mir auch wünschen, aber das Perfide an diesem Brief ist ja, dass sie alle Bedenken,
die Michael Ursprünge, die sie Michael gegenüber ursprünglich geäußert haben, jetzt nicht mehr in diesem Brief sind. Michael hatte ja bei uns in der Sendung auch einige Sachen zitiert, dass sie sagt, ja, wir haben Angst, dass jemand da eine schlechte App macht oder ein Pipapo. So und äh,
Hat dann auch hier in der Sendung gesagt, ja, all diese Einwände sind jetzt invalide, weil die Daten draußen sind. Und sie kommen jetzt nämlich über die
hintenrum Nummer und sagen, ja, aber du hast ja der, du, da, dass der Community einen Bärendienst erwiesen. Und äh wir verzichten auf auf ihre Mitarbeiter. So ein Quatsch, ja. Ich meine, der hat monatelang Arbeit investiert
um diese Daten daraus zu pulen, aufzubereiten und so weiter, der ist auf seine Kosten zu denen gefahren und hat sich mit denen unterhalten, hat um um als Open Data Evangelist ist er dort hingegangen, ohne irgendwelche Interessen, ja. Äh also ohne irgendwelche eigenen finanziellen Interessen,
Und äh jetzt kriegt er so einen Brief, also ist einfach eine Frechheit. Kündige deine Bahn Cut Tim, ich kündige auch meine Bartcard Frechheit. Wir laufen ab jetzt. Wir fahren mit einem Mercedes,
mehr ist dazu glaube ich nicht zu sagen.
Ja, nee, ich behalte meine Bank.
Ähm.
Was haben wir denn noch auf der Liste?
Es ist äh es müssen jetzt alle ihre Meinung zur Leistungsschutzrechtspetition sagen. Und zwar ähm.
Müsste man sie ja gelesen haben.
Der der Aktionstag zum Leistungsschutzrecht am zwölften Oktober, den Google ja geplant hatte, der fällt also glaube ich aus wegen ist nicht,
wir hatten ja darüber berichtet, dass Google schon im Ausland Aktivistengruppen darüber informiert hat
am zwölften Oktober in Deutschland ein Aktionstag gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht stattfindet, bevor die Größe, die Größe Zahl der Aktivistengruppen in Deutschland selber davon wusste, woraufhin die größere Anzahl der deutschen Aktivistengruppen gesagt hat
haktet und jetzt trotzdem aber,
von einigen wichtigen Gruppen und einigen äh lauten Personen dann gesagt wurde, man muss, man solle bitte diese äh Petition gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht mitzeichnen, die vor einiger Zeit von dem äh,
Bruno Kram, dem dem Piraten äh Urheberrechts ähm Typ, das ist der mit dem Cowboyhut und dem interessanten Bad. Ähm,
ins Leben gerufen wurde und äh obwohl sie einen sehr komischen,
Text hat und Bologramm auch irgendwie ein, ein Video veröffentlicht hat, in dem also das Leistungsschutzrecht,
Der Untergang des des Internets ist, mal wieder,
zu dem Markus kommentierte dass es vermutlich noch größere größere Probleme gibt die das Internet momentan bedrohen. Diese Einschätzung teile ich.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist das Lifestervice dieses dieser Gesetzentwurf zum Leistungsschutzrecht ein besonders dämliches Gesetz und es sollte auf jeden Fall verhindert werden.
Ohne dass man jetzt, sage ich mal, äh sagt, wir sind auf der Seite von Google oder wir sind auf der Seite von Axel Springer. Wir sind eigentlich,
man kann quasi einfach auf der Seite sein, dass man für sein Land und sein sein Leben ein ein beknacktes Gesetz bitte nicht haben möchte.
Und dieser dieser Positionen haben also viele äh viele Leute Ausdruck verliehen. Unter anderem der Chaos-Computer-Club, der Verein digitale Gesellschaft, äh Sascha Lovo hat irgendwas geschrieben. Und alle riefen dazu auf, ähm diese,
diese Petition, obwohl sie äh schlecht formuliert ist und ein bisschen komisch äh bitte zu unterstützen.
Und jetzt sagte dann aber der ähm Thomas Stadler äh,
argumentierte deiner Gegend, dann kam die Welle der ja derjenigen, die dagegen sind
sagen, ja, müssen wir jetzt eigentlich zu jedem Scheiß andauernd eine Petition machen? Können wir nicht diese einmalige Petition gegen netzsperren, die in Deutschland irgendwie hundertvierunddreißigtausend Zeichner erreicht und eine große Symbolkraft hat,
Können wir uns nicht endlich mal ähm können wir nicht endlich mal aufhören jetzt andauernd diesen dieser Symboltracht weiter hinterher zu eifern,
und ähm deswegen äh sagte er, ich ich zeichne die nicht. Das heißt, es gibt so eine kleine äh Debatte äh darüber, ob man die jetzt zeichnen soll oder nicht. Momentan steht die Petition ähm immer noch bei,
nicht annähernd ausreichend äh vielen Zeichnern. Und ähm,
Wollte eigentlich nur nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass das dies der Fall ist.
Aber du möchtest nicht drauf verlinken.
Ich hab's vergessen darauf zu verlinken. Den Link reiche ich nach, ja. Also ähm ich habe ich habe sie auf jeden Fall mal gezeichnet. Das kostet ja nichts.
Ähm gleichzeitig aber insbesondere interessant hat dann der,
Der Bundesrat, die Ausschüsse des federführenden Rechtsausschuss, also der der federführende Rechtsausschuss, der Ausschuss für Kulturfragen und der Wirtschaftsausschuss,
ähm,
Diese Ausschüsse des Bundesrates haben eine Empfehlung an den Bundesrat gegeben, wie er zu dem Gesetzesentwurf des Leistungsschutzrechtes Stellung zu nehmen,
habe. Und also das ist quasi die Meinung dieser drei Ausschüsse, die Teil des Bundesrates sind. Und sie sagen ähm.
Grob, dass der dass dieser von der Bundesregierung vorgelegte Gesetzesentwurf nichts sorgfältig zwischen den Interessen der Presseverleger und Journalisten ähm,
Und den Internetplattformen und Suchmaschinenanbietern auf der anderen Seite abwägt. Ähm.
Sie erkennen aber allgemein an, dass es da irgendwie ein ein Handlungsbedarf gibt, aber diesen ähm,
Diesen Vorsatz, der diesen Vorschlag findet sie jetzt irgendwie nicht in Ordnung und regen daher an, das zu prüfen, sei in wie weit die Anerkennung der verlegerischen Leistung besser in die geltende Systematik des
Rechtsgesetzes eingefügt werden kann, als sich das im Gesetzentwurf vorgeschriebene Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ähm und zwar möchten sie das äh Suchmaschinen nicht von vorneherein diskreditiert werden, sondern im Einzelfall eine kritische Würdigung ihrer urheberrechtlichen Relevanz ermöglicht wird.
Dass wir also mit diesem Leistungsschutzrichter ja so eine Keule, gibt's einen Satz und dass wir da also nicht der der Fall. Ähm,
Gleichzeitig sehen sie natürlich auch das Problem, dass so so irgendwelche Aggregatoren, die sie hier Harvester nennen, sind nicht nur äh.
Da sind Dinge so sowas wie Depub dot org, die einfach alles runterladen und und das archivieren äh und Aggregatoren, die es irgendwie aus mehreren Quellen zusammensuchen, dass dagegen irgendwie die Presseverleger auch geschützt werden müssen. Also sie erkennen da
insgesamt ein Problem an.
Als Zweites sagen sie, sie würden ganz gerne, dass äh würden ganz gerne da dadrin berücksichtigt wissen, das ist auch ganz äh ganz interessant, dass ähm,
An an wissenschaftlichen Beiträgen, wie im Rahmen einer überwiegend mit öffentlichen Mitteln finanzierten Lehr- und Forschungstätigkeit entstanden und in sind und in Sammlungen erscheinen, hat der Urheber auch bei Einräumung eines ausschließlichen Nutzungs
rechts das Recht, sein Werk längstens nach Ablauf von sechs Monaten seit Erstverlüffung Veröffentlichung anderweitig zugänglich zu machen. Das wollen sie irgendwie noch mit dadrin haben,
Ähm und dieses Recht soll quasi so formuliert sein, dass es äh wie nennt man das, nicht abgerungen werden kann. Also unveräußerliches Recht. Ähm.
Und das war etwas, wo ich noch gar nicht so dran gedacht habe. Der ähm sie möchten ganz gerne, dass die,
Im weiteren Verlauf des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens geprüft wird, ob,
diese neu geschaffene Lizenz, dieses neu geschaffene Lizensierungsrecht der Presseverlage irgendwie die Einräumung ähm eine, also die Errichtung einer Verwertungsgesellschaft,
nach sich ziehen wird. Das es heißt quasi, dass das so eine äh ZVEMA.
Zeitungsfall oder ZVEZ, Zeitungsverlags, Einzugszentrale oder sowas gibt, äh die dann irgendwie gesammelt wieder diese Rechte der Zeitungsverlage geltend macht.
Das würden sie gerne wissen, ob sowas geplant sei oder ob das äh rechtlich sein müsste oder sein dürfte oder.
Es könnte quasi ähm also es gibt momentan äh laut Gesetzesentwurf keine Verwertungsgesellschaft Pflichtigkeit.
Und ähm,
Wenn es eine Verwertungsgesellschaftpflichtigkeit gäbe, argumentiert der, die akumentieren die Ausschüsse, dann würde, würden die würden diese Regelungen sehr viel praktikabler werden.
Ja, also dann hast du nicht mehr irgendwie ganz viele Einzelabsprachen, sondern es würden sich irgendwie alle Zeitungsverlage in eine Verwertungsgesellschaft zusammentun. Äh und dann hätten wir eine noch so eine GEMA
die kümmert sich dann um was weiß ich Rahmenverträge mit den großen Anbietern und so weiter und so und setzt die Rechte durch.
Es geht alles noch hin und her, aber es gibt auch politischen Widerstand zu dem aktuellen Entwurf.
Ja, das genau, also zu dem aktuellen Entwurf, ja, Sie erkennen aber trotzdem irgendwie die Sie sagen schon, dass Sie die Schwierigkeit anerkennen und äh nur diese die aktuelle Formulierung nicht so in in Ordnung finden.
Ja? Interessant.
Und dann haben sie noch so einen kleinen irgendwie einen Satz äh sollte ein, zwei Sätze sollten noch geändert werden. Aber Bundesrat also findet den den aktuellen Text beknackt,
aber sieht die allgemeine Notwendigkeit äh offensichtlich trotzdem äh gegeben,
Das Presseverlagen irgendwie Schutz gegen.
Das schließt sozusagen dann die SPD auch mit ein.
Ich weiß leider nicht, wer jeweils der Vorsitzende dieser äh dieser Ausschüsse ist. Da muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz schauen.
Das ist ja sozusagen auch eine Frage wie die SPD eigentlich ich meine generell hat sie sich ja skeptisch geäußert, wenn ich das richtig äh in Erinnerung habe. Ich meine, auf so einer Art und Weise, wo man sich jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt so sicher sein kann, ob das.
Also Rechtsausschuss ist auf jeden Fall Jana Shidek. Äh von der SPD äh die Vorsitzende. Ähm,
Das heißt, ja, aber ich meine das ja auch wirklich, dass er jetzt wieder irgendwie so einen Ausschuss, ne, das heißt, das ist jetzt wieder nur der, was die Ausschüsse dem Bundesrat nahelegen, was er denn bitte dem Bundestag, beziehungsweise der Bundesregierung, antworten möchte.
Ja, es ist äh noch so wirklich eine eine sehr noch eine Vorstufe.
Gucken, wer die Ausschuss für Kulturfragen, wer da die Vorsitzenden sind.
Also mit anderen Worten, auch das muss ja auch vom Bundesrat dann auch erstmal abgesegnet werden und da kommt es dann einfach nochmal.
Könnte spannend werden, ja.
Drauf an, wie da die Länder äh koalieren.
Also Ausschuss für Kulturfragen ist auch der SPD-Vorsitz und äh Wirtschaftsausschuss.
Ist äh Martin Zeil von der FDP äh der Vorsitzende.
So, die haben also jetzt äh dieses dieses äh also man man kann da quasi so ein bisschen das lässt ja vielleicht so ein bisschen darauf äh vorhören, wie also ein Bundesrat sich im Zweifelsfall zu diesem Text äh positioniert.
Gut, ich glaube, damit haben wir es aber auch jetzt äh ausreichend beleuchtet.
Genau, Link für die Petition ist online und äh sie ist, glaube ich, bald vorbei und weit davon entfernt fünfzigtausend Zeichner zu haben.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird nix.
Ja, da gehört trotzdem noch mal. Also wer möchte, sollte dann sich jetzt beeilen.
Wie auch immer äh außerhalb von Deutschland in äh anderen europäischen Ländern gibt es äh dann noch andere interessante Entwicklungen, insbesondere was das äh generelle Verhältnis zu Fallshering,
Netzwerken betrifft, äh besonders hervor getan, hat sich hier ein Gericht in Portugal.
Ähm einfach mal ähm,
befunden hat, dass so das private Austausch ähm von Dateien über Netzwerken ja so generell eigentlich erst mal nicht so falsch,
wäre und in konkreten Fall die äh beantragte Herausgabe von IP-Adressen dann.
Zweitausend Nutzer.
Abgelehnt hat.
Dass er seine Antipiraterievereinigung, die wollte zweitausend Tauschbörsennutzer,
gegen die Verfahren einleiten, weil sie sich an.
Also was bei uns hier so gang und gäbe ist, wird dort äh in Aprede gestellt, zumindest durch dieses Gericht. Ähm man ruft sich da auch auf ähm ja, Informationsfreiheit und äh,
Bildung und Kultur, die ja nicht eingeschränkt werden dürften und auch nicht würden, wenn äh mögliche Copyright äh Verstöße äh
nicht gewerblichen Charakter haben. Und das ist natürlich interessant, weil das so ein bisschen so eigentlich die ursprüngliche Sicht unseres äh,
Privatkopie äh ähm ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das durchs Gesetz abgedeckt war, aber,
wovon die Politik ja an zunehmenden Maße abrückt und,
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, äh welchen Einfluss könnte das haben? Ja, also es gibt zumindest in Portugal da einen Wandel,
Niederlanden allerdings.
Warte, ich will noch, ich will noch ganz kurz klären, in Portugal muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz, weil wir ja immer technische Sachen auch nochmal erläutern sollen. Ähm.
Ist deswegen in Anführungszeichen privat, weil es wirklich eine Tauschbörse ist, wo also die alle, die das runterladen,
gleichzeitig miteinander Dateien teilen. Das heißt, während ich die Datei runterlade und auch darüber hinaus, stelle ich sie gleichzeitig auch anderen zur Verfügung. Lade selber die Datei aus einem Schwarm
von sehr vielen Quellen herunter. Was deswegen auch meistens dazu führt, dass ich sie sehr schnell herunterladen kann
und äh habe damit eigentlich eine sehr effiziente Nutzung des Netzwerkes, also eigentlich ein Protokoll, was äh was sehr sehr äh sehr positiv zu betrachten ist
Gleichzeitig führt es aber dazu, dass jeder, der da selber mit herunterlädt, meine IP-Adresse bekommt und.
Also nicht jeder, sondern eine Auswahl von, genau. Ja?
Aber meine IP-Adresse bekommen kann.
Genauen bekommen könnte. Mhm.
Und ähm das ist also das wie Abmahnkanzleien dagegen vorgehen. Die schalten sich in diesen Toren mit ein
beteiligen sich daran, laden selber mit herunter und macht dann eine Liste von IP-Adressen, die sich daran beteiligt haben, äh holen lassen sich von den äh jeweiligen
Providern, die äh Daten geben und äh schreiben dann Briefe an diese Person. Ähm,
Der Hintergrund dafür ist, dass man, dass man in Deutschland sagt, das ist zwar
privates File-Sharing, das hat aber kommerzielles Ausmaß, weil es äh geschäftsschädigend für uns ist,
mit ähnlichen Argumentationen geht man dann gegen die Seiten an, die quasi die Informationen bereitstellen, wie man sich in diesen Schwarm mit äh hineinklinken kann mit seiner Software,
ähm zwei zweifellos ist es äh aber verboten äh,
Wenn ich jetzt quasi auf meiner Internetseite einfach was anbiete. Dann wäre ich also, das wäre keine äh kein Tausch mehr, sondern das wäre eine eine öffentliche Zugänglichmachung mit wahrscheinlich dann kommerziellem Hintergrund. Ähm,
und nur diese Tauschbörsen, also eigentlich das, was in Deutschland die einzige ernstzunehmende Gefahr ist für den ambitionierten Downloader.
Wenn ihr irgendwie zu Rapid Share geht oder zu äh mega Upload, ach nee, also zu irgend so einem zu irgend so einem Anbieter ähm,
und da etwas herunterlädt, dann ist die äh Gefahr, dabei erwischt zu werden, sehr gering und zweitens auch äh ist das rechtlich gar nicht so kritisch, weil der Anbieter, hier ist ein klare Definition, wer Anbieter und wer Konsument ist,
und ähm darüber man die Leute platt macht, die sich an Torend äh beteiligen ist nicht, dass sie heruntergeladen haben, sondern.
Dass sie dadurch auch automatisch angeboten.
Dass sie angeboten haben,
Das ist ein interessanter äh das ist hier der der interessante Unterschied. Und in Portugal wird jetzt gesagt, genau dieses Anbieten, das ist völlig okay. Das das ist in Ordnung. Das könnt ihr, könnt ihr so machen,
und ähm das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante äh interessante Entwicklung. Gleichzeitig,
Ähm und da kommen wir dann zu den Niederlanden. Die haben grade äh eine, die haben momentan eine Gesetzeslage, die quasi illegale Downloads für private Zwecke erlaubt,
Also es ist ein ähnlicher Zustand wohl. Ähm,
Wie in ähm wie in Portugal. Und der Grund dafür ist, dass Sie sagen, das Recht auf also Ihr Recht auf Privatkopie ist so formuliert, dass es nicht,
sagt, es darf nur aus einer legalen Quelle kommen. Weil sie sagen, es gibt ein Recht auf Privatkopie.
Und sie haben in dem Gesetz in diesem Recht äh auf Privatkopie äh vergessen, zu schreiben, es gibt ein Recht auf Privatkopie aus legaler Quelle.
Wie auch immer man sich vorstellen sollte, wie sie wie dieser Satz dann tatsächlich formuliert werden sollte. Aber das äh die die Lage scheint also zu sein, dass jemand, der sich irgendwie in in einem bitteren Schwarm beteiligt, dann sagt, ja Privatkopie,
Alles klar, so und ähm damit kommen sie im Moment offensichtlich in Niederlanden durch,
Es gibt aber eine äh Copyright-Direktive ähm.
Der europäischen Union, diese, die irgendwie sagt, okay, da die Quelle spielt sicherlich auch noch irgendwie eine Rolle und die Niederlande wollen jetzt prüfen lassen, ob ihre Regelung mit der europäischen Copyright-Detektive kompatibel ist.
Und wenn mal wenn die Niederlande Pech haben, dann ähm würde es heißen, dass quasi Privatkopie nur für legale Quellen gilt.
Und dann wäre die Frage, äh ist diese Direktive verbindlich für alle Mitgliedsstaaten oder nur für oder ist es quasi äh kann man sich, kann man da ein bisschen von abweichen von dieser Copyright-Direktive?
Ja, ist sehr interessant, dass,
Für dich auch ausgerechnet auf juristischer Ebene in unterschiedlichen Ländern auch so differenzierte Sichtweisen dazu Tage treten, die da auch so ein bisschen von dem äh Copyright Mainstream
abweichen und versuchen da einen Punkt zu machen und versuchen auch.
Das Phänomen des privaten Kopierens und Verteilens in irgendeiner Form zu fassen.
Also Dinge sind in Bewegung.
Ja, also es ist glaube ich auch wirklich nur in Deutschland grade so, dass das Thema Urheberrecht so so völlig äh durchgeknallt, behandelt wird von allen,
Es gab anscheinend nicht EU-weit wirklich so diese diese Historie, sind nur momentan nur in Deutschland, dass das das über dieses Thema nicht mehr ähm,
Äh diskutiert werden kann.
Gut, womit wir.
Jeden Fall wär's scharf und würde den portugiesischen VPN-Anbietern, ja? Also,
die haben jetzt echt, die können jetzt wirklich mal ein äh paar Millionen Euro Lobby auf auf darauf werfen, dass dass das so äh dass das so Bestand behält, ja?
Das wäre natürlich ein Traum, ja? Portugiesische VPNs sind auf jeden Fall jetzt äh in den nächsten Wochen ähm sage ich mal, das wo man äh Aktien kaufen möchte.
Mhm. Interessanter Punkt, wenn ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Wir brauchen eigentlich nur ein Land, weißt du, der.
Es reicht. Ja, Linus.
Du wolltest noch eine Veranstaltung erwähnen.
Genau, es sind ähm.
Es ist nächste Woche, das ist der dreizehnte und vierzehnte Oktober, ist äh wieder einmal Zeit für die Datenspuren,
glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt.
Wir hatten kurz erwähnt, dass es.
Aber jetzt steht es sozusagen auch mit Programm. Äh im Netz.
Ist ja eigentlich so ein Tradition, weil's jetzt Veranstaltung, dass man nicht so früh sagt, worum's eigentlich geht. Ähm trotz alledem gibt's jetzt das detaillierte Programm zum Nachschlagen und der Datenspuren,
DE
und wie der Name schon nahe liegt, äh geht's hier viel um Privacy et cetera. Ich habe die Datenspuren über die Jahre. Ich war, glaube ich,
Bis auf eine war ich, glaube ich, immer da. Einfach weil ich äh ja ohnehin äh das ähm,
wie soll ich sagen, wie man sich's wie wie alles sich in Dresden so gibt, immer ganz, ganz toll finde und äh das gerne als Anlass nehme, nach Dresden zu fahren, aber trotzdem ist auch die Veranstaltung dementsprechend
entspannt
und da kann man gut ins Gespräch kommen, sage ich mal. Ist nicht so eine maßlose überrannte Veranstaltung, so ein paar hundert Leute und äh das ist einfach ein guter Ort, um da äh,
interessante Menschen kennenzulernen und diese ganzen Themen auch mal vor Ort in Ruhe zu,
diskutieren letztes Mal und ich glaube auch diesmal wieder ist auch da so ein bisschen Hackereibeschäftigung. Ähm,
Erdgeschoss möglich, da wird also auch viel äh gebastelt und getan und auch Kinder hatten da eine Menge Spaß. Also ist das vielleicht eine Empfehlung für einen Wochenendausflug?
In Dresden. Wir finden das gut.
Ich werde den Ausflug auch machen, allerdings nur am Sonntag und dort einen äh kurzen Vortrag halten. Ähm muss den aber jetzt hinten noch vorbereiten.
Im Penta Barf habe ich, glaube ich, einen Titel, ja. Ich hoffe, dass jetzt noch nicht ach so, scheiße, die haben das Programm jetzt veröffentlicht, ne? Ja, dann habe ich einen äh Titel, den muss ich noch mal ändern, der war scheiße.
Ich habe nur so ein, so ein, so einen Platzhalter eigentlich da äh in das Penta Barf geworfen. Ähm.
Also hier steht ein Netzneutralität, wer was, wieso?
Völlig bescheuert.
Ja gut, aber auch bescheuerte Titel können mit Inhalt ausgefüllt werden.
Ja, müssen wir nochmal gucken, da müssen wir ein bisschen anderen Titel, also Titelvorschläge gerne äh Themen Thema können wir nicht mehr ändern.
Also du wirst sie zuletzt Neutralität äußern und du hast sozusagen auch das letzte Wort am Sonntag?
Ja, das war Bedingung, wie im Bus, ne, die coolen Hinten.
Ja, verstehe. Du bist sozusagen das Highlight.
Ja, ich will, ich komme dann, wenn die.
Letzte auf Bäumen.
Echt die letzte, scheiße, ich habe meinen Zurück, mein Sofa fährt erst sehr spät abends. Nach Hause, dann bin ich da noch in Dres.
Ach na ja, Andres.
Gegensatz zu dir, ich ich kenne ja Dresden immer nur von den Nazifrei-Demos und ich halte ja Dresden so für echte.
Ja, dann kannst du dir mal das andere Bild dann mal äh vermitteln lassen. Das ist doch auch schön. Dann kannst du das schön ausklingen lassen. Nochmal ein paar Stündchen schön durch den Kiez.
Frauenkirche gucke ich mir dann an.
Latschen, ne.
Ja, Dresden, ja ja wird sicherlich ganz äh.
Ja, Dresden ist ist ein sehr äh sehr knuffiger Ort. Ich kann das nur empfehlen. So, dann haben wir es aber jetzt auch. Das war die vierzigste Ausgabe übrigens von Lok Buchenetzpolitik. Wir machen uns, haben wir eigentlich das Jahr schon rum?
Nee, am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober ist der Jahrestag der die Gründung des Logbos. Es ist ein Sonntag.
Buch Republik,
Republik-Lockbuch-Netzpolitik. Ja, äh, wir können's gleich verraten, wir planen keine Geburtstagsparty. Es wird sich leider zu diesem Datum nicht ergeben können.
Wir feiern schon eine, aber äh wir haben nicht so viel ähm Champagner, dass wir die öffentlich machen, deswegen werden Tim und ich uns mit einem paar Freundinnen aufm Land,
anschließen und im kleinen Kreise.
Mond dehnt abfeiern. Gut vielen Dank für äh euer Interesse und das war's. Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.